kind of like betting like I see your
conspiracy theory and I raised you my
mom sent me articles about conspiracy
stories on WeChat one of the most
memorable ones is about flu shot so
according to this conspiracy story all
the flu shots are actually made by
aliens
apparently aliens and American
government have made a deal aliens
wanted to slowly change human race to
aliens by injecting flu shot at least
once a year just like iPhone upgrade the
most memorable whatsapp conspiracy
theory that my mom sent me was this
picture and it was so graphic it was
like a blown-up hand next to a phone and
I'm like mom why are you sending me this
underneath it it's like this big long
paragraph about how talking to your
phone is really bad and like it also has
a high chance of exploding and so under
that my mom puts Selim please don't put
your phone up to your face anymore it's
bad it's like when you get these
messages from your parents just say okay
don't debate them on it don't say
anything just say okay and move on so
this one I don't even have the contact
saves so just as a phone number but for
knowing me oh boy knows they say us a
Louisville DSO in a sad way so I'm not
just any my famous video
essentially what these long as message
is trying to say is that secret Chinese
operatives have created highly advanced
technology I can hide phishing
information in good morning pictures
good night gifts and cute little videos
so you should not be sending your
friends and family cat pictures or dog
videos cuz your credit card PIN will get
stolen I use facebook Messenger and
whatsapp to communicate with my mom she
will send me articles videos and
everything in between she automatically
sends me you know article that if I am
walking around barefoot I'm gonna get
sick
or if I sit on the cot concrete I'm
gonna get a UTI so my uncle all he does
is kind of like surf the web and I think
he's in the Deep Web for sure because he
finds weird-ass videos and sends them to
us so like he sent my entire family like
every person in my family and probably
other people outside our family this
video that claims chicken meat that we
eat is actually wrecked me and like it
got so bad that you know months and
weeks have passed and on multiple
occasions like my dad at family
gatherings was like just bring up the
source and be like yeah I heard you know
the chicken we're eating is actually rat
this is wrong information when he sends
me anything I still need to respond like
I feel bad I'm not gonna not reply this
daily probably routine it's part of his
day because my parents don't trust me
living in America by myself therefore
they send me a lot of conspiracy stories
to make me be more cautious I think she
was she just wants us to be aware of
everything and take care of ourselves at
the end of the day immigrant parents are
always just trying to keep us safe so
that's why they send us all this crazy
stuff I think at the heart of it is
really like the video of like I care
about my family member and I want them
to know that and that ranges from a cute
picture of your kid to something's
happening with the CIA and we didn't
know about it I think at the end of the
day I might miss them when she does stop
sending me those articles I would say
keep on sending him past is is great
[Music]
you